jason rantz is a radio show host up in
seattle he has that story for us tonight
hey jason
hey tucker the the country's wokest
guaranteed income scheme is coming from
palm springs run by lisa middleton this
is the state's first transgender mayor
the plan is effectively meant to help
prevent homelessness by giving 20
residents somewhere between 600 and 900
a month for nearly two years and they
can spend the money however it is they
want there's no strings attached the
only rule at this point is that the
recipients have to be transgender or
pretend they're genderless or have
multiple genders based on one's mood
gender doesn't actually mean anything
anymore and this is not something that
really you can prove
so instead
of primarily focusing on using this to
end poverty there's been this focus on
paying for what's called gender
affirming health care which includes
elective surgeries and hormone treatment
now the city hopes to use some of a 35
million dollar budget set up by
california democrats to fund various
pilot programs around the state but big
picture this is really a movement by a
group called mayors for guaranteed
income they think that redistribution of
wealth actually solves poverty it's
backed by folks like jack dorsey who
tried to ruin the world with twitter now
he said on another pretty dangerous idea
here's one palm springs council member
inadvertently pointing out that this is
pretty much a huge scam
the bureaucracies that we've set up to
fund poverty programs and to staff them
are probably much more expensive than
giving people the money who need it
now she goes on to point out that this
is really just about getting the data
necessary to prove that this whole
scheme works but much like the people
it's supposed to help in palm springs
guaranteed income presents as a good
idea it's not actually a good one and
all the data seems to point out that it
doesn't quite get us to the point of
defeating poverty in a way that is
efficient with the use of use of funding
it's just too expensive
well and of course it just reflects
elite concerns i mean you know we had a
hundred thousand people die of drug ods
last year like why don't you know for
passing out money how about their
families no they're not fashionable got
to be nothing not for treatment of
course whatever that is yeah jason rice
great to see you thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight